a general strike with what was promised
general chaos across Hong Kong and
before the Sun even set is what people
got
[Applause]
it was very different earlier Monday
morning and Central Hong Kong was
deserted
many had responded to protesters calls
to strike but many more simply couldn't
get to work
protesters had blocked the doors of
subway trains to stop them running and
put barricades across roads at the
airport absent air traffic controllers
meant more than 200 flights were
canceled striking workers had plenty of
support shutting down Hong Kong's
economy which effectively the strike is
doing is that a good idea well it's well
for one day or even one week well
bringing some kind of reminder so you
support the strike yes I probably but
there wasn't a total shutdown and some
were not happy you didn't join the
strike today I think it's very stupid
destroy Hong Kong Hong is a very good
place don't stop destroy Hong Kong Hong
Kong gap is the best home from parties
it's best at a rare news conference Hong
Kong's chief executive condemned the
strike and the broader protests such
extensive disruptions in a name of
certain demands or uncooperative
movement have seriously undermined Hong
Kong's law and order and are pushing our
city the city we all love and many of us
helped to build through the verge of a
very dangerous situation
it already feels dangerous protesters
stop disrupting transport together
initially peacefully in seven locations
across Hong Kong after some threw stones
police responded with canister a point
canister of tear gas to be cleared
protesters used traffic cones to contain
the smoke Hong Kong's government shows
no sign of being able to contain this
Andrew Thomas al Jazeera Hong Kong